[Musique]
vite vite
oui ok alors dès que tu pourras traverse
la rue sur ta gauche à gauche bon à
gauche voilà
il
continue tout droit
dubois du coup droit et maintenant nous
sommes à droite à droite là tout de
suite oui tout à droite et sur wii non à
gauche je tourne à gauche par non
l'écran était verrouillée
bah qu'est ce que tu fous je me prépare
à sauter d'un immeuble prépare à sauter
d'un hymne à t'accorde désolé j'étais en
2d bonne chance mission impossible
fallout mission impossible format août
il n'a pu y avoir de paix sont d'abord
une grande souffrance
plus la souffrance est grande plus la
buvée grande halle afin que vous avez
toujours redouté gauche et c'est vous
qui allez morts sur la conscience
j'ai prié pour que ce ne soit pas vrai
salomone line s'est évadé à paris et
maintenant le monde est en danger c'est
la mission de la cia vous utiliser un
scalpel
je préfère un marteau c'est pas une
bonne idée
c'est parce qu'on dit à chaque fois
honnêtement
il n'est pas là que pour observer c'est
un tueur
je n'ai confiance quand vous trois
si vous dérapez il est autorisé à vous
tuer ce sont les ordres
sans rancune
tu es ou benji bon à gauche
ça les papilles mais qu'est ce que tu
attends je sente du haut d'un immeuble à
pas de chance
quand le vent va tourner et tourner à
nous de perdre à tous ceux qu'il a aimés
tu ne sais pas de quoi tu t'engages et
tu ferais mieux de temps d'aller
s'il te plaît contre toi
ça ne nous ressemble pas rétabli
peut-être qu'il est temps que ça change
[Musique]
accepter le retail ce qui est fait est
fait qu'amener
c'est terminé quand nous décidons que
c'est terminé c'est parti
[Musique]
mission impossible forlan ou cinéma le
1er août